【音乐】
Hello 大家好 欢迎来到这期的怀鲁写真集 我是海鲁。
我是正雅
那么今天的这期节目呢？
我们又为大家带来了一期用声音散步的。
这么一个大恩比较特殊的节目。
嗯
然后今天我们要带大家去的地方呢？
是东京很有名的
然后以及喜欢音乐的人一定非常熟悉的地方。
就是大名鼎鼎的Tava Records。
Tava Records。
对 然后它中文翻译过来。
大家一般喜欢叫它塔音或者是塔电。
那么至于我们作为一个摄影博主。
为什么突然来了这么一期。
看上去非常偏向音乐的题目呢？
是因为我们发现首先在。
现在公众事业里面。
大家的爱好其实有成对出现的这种迹象。
对
就比如说我会发现咖啡音乐摄影。
然后旅行这四个东西经常会排列组合一下。
两两出现或者三三出现在同一个人身上。
对
而且我觉得就是如果你喜欢摄影。
你不可能不爱音乐吧？
然后如果你爱音乐的话。
你也大概率会喜欢影像啊？
对吧？
就是他们都是相通的。
对
而且本身你看很多漂亮的专辑封面。
它就是很好的摄影载体。
对
你进入到一家比如唱片店。
或者你翻看你的所有唱片的时候。
你总是会被图像袭击。
是的
因为音乐本身还是没有形状的一个东西。
我觉得就是在今天会喜欢摄影。
喜欢音乐的人一定都是非常注重生活方式的这种选择。
生活会更细腻一点对不对。
对
就主要你是靠感性去做这个判断吗？
在现在这么一个非常AI化的时代里。
感性这个东西还是非常非常有人味的。
是的
然后以及我们现在的工作。
其实也是在被我们自己的兴趣爱好所支配了。
所污染
对
其实我们最初是绝大部分工作要去做影像类的东西。
但是现在我们可能有近乎一半的经历要放到声音相关的工作。
以及把它怎么去包装去处理好一点的这种工作内容。
对
然后我们也会给一些很棒很棒的这种大的播客去做录音师。
如果大家之前有去看那个小宇宙的创作者学院。
你们也会发现快乐写真机的节目。
对
所以这就是为什么我们作为一个名字叫写真机的。
听起来像是摄影频道的频道。
今天想客串一把音乐播出。
对
然后来给大家讲一讲我们生活中另外一个非常重要的娱乐部分。
来带大家逛一下我们非常喜欢的一家唱片店。
我们的生活也从唱片店中急取到了很多很多的养分。
今天就想从我们的视角。
然后带大家比较沉浸式的去逛一下。
位于东京色古站的Tauver Record。
就是也是它最大的这样的一家门店。
然后带大家一起去探索关于流行音乐的一些魅力。
那上来先整体的做一点介绍。
就是我在看很多旅游攻略的时候会发现。
他们会推荐大家去这家西伟亚的Tauver Record的店。
是在于它是亚洲最大的单体唱片店。
然后以及Tauver Records本身也是应该现在是全球最大的实体唱片店。
它的实体线下店应该是有80多家。
并且还在有不断的开心店的计划。
我觉得就是可能对于一个年轻。
比我们还有年轻的朋友来讲。
就觉得还挺离谱的。
就是现在互联网这么发达流媒体。
这么有趣
对吧？
无论是像王毅云QQ音乐Apple Music。
Bodify其实都做出花样了。
价格也很便宜其实。
然后为什么还有很多人会去实体唱片店去买这个碟呢？
然后为什么塔店还能有80多家门店。
在不断的开心店呢？
就很离谱这个事情。
我觉得这个点其实除以你离远的看。
可能很容易轻易的给它一个定义。
你就会觉得说是不是日本人脑子比较轴。
但实际上我跟我的日本Tony聊天的时候。
我就会问他说你还会去吗？
我问他你自己还会去。
他说我不去
我不买实体唱片了。
我都流媒体就好
所以我觉得这个答案也不能规划说。
日本人所有人都喜欢实体唱片。
然后同时当我们逛过Tauver Records之后。
我觉得也不能用比如最大的唱片店来概括它。
因为其实它一共有八层加地下九层。
这九层如果你一路逛下来。
你获得的体验更像是在日本近30年的流行乐史。
或者唱片店史里面穿梭了一遍。
所以这是我们响应声音带大家来。
在这么一个单体的店里漫步一期节目。
其实还挺长的这么一个过程。
好吧？
那我有点迫不及待了。
那就让我们真正的开始走进吉布亚的这一家Tauver Records。
那大家如果想到这家喜不压的Tauver Records。
其实最方便的就是做JR也好。
或者经往线小便级也好。
你就直接到喜不压站下车就好。
对
喜不压其实也算是。
现在如果你要去东京旅游。
或者你生活在东京的话。
你肯定很难错过的一站。
因为它超级大
然后包容了非常多的商场商业。
然后同时它可能相比于银座。
比如新宿这种更老一点的商业圈来讲。
它会更加的流行
更加pop一点
年轻人会都比较喜欢去。
而且像这两年可能大家因为看周末回站的。
那个做故事片的每年。
所以大家会更加的喜欢去喜不压地区一点。
而且现在喜不压的那个大的路口。
基本上就是成为了日本的世界的名片了。
他们之前奥运会开场。
或者他们很多的介绍。
这个国家和城市的那个地标。
一定会选择这个大的路口。
那首先先带大家用声音听一段。
就是在喜不压街头。
然后我们走到Tauver Records店上的这个声音。
大家能听到就是喜不压其实是一个非常热闹的街区。
能听到很多人在走路。
然后有年轻人的声音。
还有跑车的声音
有时候你还会赶上那个很著名的那个。
麻辽的那个小卡丁车。
特别吵嘟嘟嘟的在那里。
而且喜不压是一个非常国际化的地方。
就是你身边肯定不只是日本人。
然后你听到的语言也一定不只是日语。
全世界的游客更多。
所以你站在那你再往Tauver Records那个方向去走的时候。
我觉得就有一种非常世界非常pop的感觉。
那个节奏就已经开始了。
对人很多走路很快。
然后他们直到走到Tauver Records附近。
就能开始听到那个店内的音乐。
不断的从那个门份里流出来的感觉。
对就开始吸引着你。
就把你要吸进去了。
那当我们站在这个店门口的时候。
然后就会听到非常日本代表性的偶像文化的那种意义。
就是你喜欢
也不能说我喜欢
曾经的你喜欢的那种。
不是
就是你听他现在放的这个曲子啊？
大家也可以听一下。
他这个其实是那种非常怎么说的。
24元
对 而且就是日本的工业化偶像是这样的。
大家知道就是韩国的工业化偶像也很有名的。
它是K-pop那种很帅的感觉。
然后日本就是这种小姑娘在卖萌的那个感觉。
那么穿过了这一片就是偶像的声音走进店内。
其实我们非常推荐大家的一个漫步线路。
是直接上到顶层去。
然后从上一层一层的往下逛。
嗯 是的
我觉得这个还挺不一样的。
因为比如说如果女生去逛一些比较好的商场。
然后它的商场的设计一般都是比较重要的大牌。
或者化妆品什么的都在一楼嘛？
然后可能女装啊什么的。
就是她会根据价位。
然后在二楼三楼
然后越往上可能就是是男装或者说是什么家具用品了。
就是其实你还是一个从下往上的浏览的路线。
但是塔店确实不一样。
它稍微有点文化行业的那个特性。
然后像大家如果逛过类似于书店这样的场景的话。
其实书店我觉得都没有塔店这么极端的一种。
就是说楼层的分布感。
然后像西班牙塔店因为有八层嘛？
所以非常有名
从我的角度观看更像是它的历史沉淀顺序的道具。
啊 就是越往上的可能越经典。
对 就比如说越下面的越是它流行的新业务。
比如说一楼可能是当前最流行。
然后大热歌手他正在发的心底。
对 然后到二楼是它的那个咖啡厅的部分。
就是有时候会搞一些像那个小偶像见面会啊？
或者说相关周边联动的那种咖啡厅。
它这是一个对日本唱片店来说比较新的业台。
然后它放在二楼
然后再往上等于它是按时间慢慢道序上去的一个感觉。
那越靠近最上面的楼层越接近它。
开店时就拥有的那个业务范围。
啊 就是一种道序嘛？
对 就是一种道序感。
所以如果你对某一类音乐类型特别感兴趣的人。
那你可能就是直奔你喜欢的那一层就好了。
对 比如说你就想买当下的这个热门歌手。
比如说腾顶峰的这个新专辑。
那你基本上你去一楼你赶时间。
然后你直接另一张你就买走了。
比如说你喜欢K-POP。
然后你可以直接去K-POP那一层。
但如果你像我们这种就是特别咸。
然后有的时候我就想花一下。
我甚至一个晚上我就要把这个塔店逛透。
或者说我根本不知道我今天想买什么蝶。
但是我就是想要去像逃音乐一样。
去逃唱片一样像发掘新东西。
那你可以参考一下我们的路线。
就是我们会从最顶层一路下来把它逛透。
对 或者就是如果你是纯绿油嘛？
你把这当一经典儿。
啊 你觉得这个经典儿它不太一样。
它不是那种买门票进去的东西。
但是一个就是你需要真的很爱音乐。
你才愿意在这么一个店里面花半天时间的话。
那你也很适合我们推荐的从上往下的路线。
嗯 是的
嗯 那我们就一路先进店以后。
坐着电梯一路往上去。
对 我觉得塔店的这个电梯首先就非常有意思。
对 因为其实坐电梯的这个体验。
我觉得在西伯亚的这家Tauror Records。
是特别重要的一个可以称之为小景点的一个环节。
是的 因为你在坐电梯的过程中。
你一边可以听到每层对应主题的这个音乐。
它正在播放的这个音乐。
同时你眼前
无论是你头顶上还是两侧的墙壁上。
都会张贴着各种音乐人的这个海报。
嗯 对
然后尤其头顶上主要是主打它No Music No Life系列的海报。
对 然后侧面会看到茫茫多。
甚至中间偶尔加在有签名款的稀有的海报。
对 然后侧面这个No Music No Life也是特别有名。
然后侧面也有一个官方的中文翻译。
就是无音乐无人声。
然后侧面很多特别有名的这个艺人。
日本的音乐人
他都会有一张自己的这个No Music No Life。
比如说什么戏也行尘啊？
然后雨多天光啊？
然后汪蒂啊等等
就是你一路坐电梯坐上去。
你就能看到这些人的这个No Music No Life的这个海报。
我觉得从上电梯这个过程看海报的体验。
就已经是一个密度超高的展览了。
嗯 因为里面全都是摄影作品构成的海报。
对
他每一张因为机店的足够多嘛？
有很多很多日本的音乐界人士。
然后甚至有时候有一些文化界人士。
都会参与到No Music No Life这个海报项目里来。
是
然后同时在上去的过程中。
你会发现比如他会有一些非这个系列的。
比如像在那个洋乐在那个海外流行的那一层。
你就能看到更多比如当季的艺人主题的海报。
嗯 是
像那个Tiler Swift的一排新的彩色海报。
就在那个No Music No Life里面显得特别的显眼了。
是 是 是
然后他还会有一些比如说。
米金玄师给一个日本乐队。
然后写的这种推荐语一样的文章。
然后他也会做成海报。
然后账贴在那里
嗯 然后还会有那种特殊款。
尤其是塔店自己
喜不压店会喜欢拿出来炫耀的一类海报。
就是比如这个明星拍了No Music No Life之后。
他会做一个签名款。
同时还写好是TOO Power Record的喜不压店。
对对对
所以这种海报就是当出现在眼前的时候。
你会觉得如果是你喜欢的那个艺人。
你都会觉得这是一种巨大的炫耀。
这个唱片店在炫耀自己拥有多么强的音乐界的人脉。
然后那么一路走到最顶层。
其实像我们去的那天就是最顶层没有开。
嗯 对 八楼那天正好在装修。
对 然后简单介绍一下。
八楼对于喜不压店来说是古典约的classical。
然后他对外宣称自己是日本最大的单层的classical floor。
他说就是日本第一。
对 日本第一 古典约大屏层。
古典约也是积累的时间最长久的一个音乐品类。
嗯 对 所以被他们放到最上面那一层。
而且我感觉就是可能越往上的层的品类。
它就越需要你安静的就是慢慢的去探索和欣赏的那一层。
嗯 对 然后所以我们当天去录音的这一天。
是其实是从七层开始逛的。
然后七层呢是算是世界流行吧？
在这里你比较印象深刻的是能一下找到bitos。
然后找到queen这些级别的乐队会放在最外面。
然后最显眼的那个位置都是就是最人气的那种。
或者他觉得最经典的那个。
就是这个专辑放在这里放20年每年都会有人来买的。
不会过时的东西
你如果做电梯
然后从六楼到七楼的侧面的墙壁上。
现在贴的都是tillus weave的彩色海报。
嗯 对 然后很多欧美的这种大牌艺人都会被放到七楼去售卖。
对 然后像我记得当时我们逛的时候。
正好赶上bluenomeus的那个新专辑在出嘛？
然后就会给他布置一个小展台。
然后关于他这张专辑的各种形式的cd甚至还要四代。
然后还有专辑相关的小周边。
就都在他的那个小摊上。
嗯 对 然后像这一层在他的官网介绍里还特意会说。
这里有着全日本最大的这个亚洲音乐专区。
里面不仅有大家理解的这种就是说那个cpuff。
中国流行乐的这种亚洲流行。
然后甚至还有印度一点的。
然后韩国的菲律宾的。
总之只要地理上在亚洲的流行乐在这里。
他甚至会有一个区域是特别去收录他的。
然后所以在七层呢？
其实你逛到的是就是最世界的那一面。
嗯 就是世界最流行。
对 世界最流行的那个金曲汇集。
流行金曲
buboard
对 然后他说就是从这个最新的话题大热的点。
然后到那种就是超级经典的。
每个人都要买一张的那种体验都会收录在这里。
他也不只是就是puff类的嘛？
jazz啊rock啊这些就是大部分的。
音乐流派的金曲都会被收集到这里。
所以其实这里就体现的是一个就是综合感。
嗯 嗯
讲到这里其实我觉得他就和tower records自己本身的这个发展是非常的怎么说的一致的一个感觉。
嗯 就我了解这个tower record原本是美国的一个厂牌对不对。
对 然后甚至我前两天还在想说刷到就是说有人在日本tower records买完碟之后。
然后有售后问题他去给美国的tower records写了邮件。
然后呢 然后这个邮件被转到转到日本。
对 然后其实这个也是我觉得可能很多人知道这个店但是不了解的一个背景。
就可能很多人会觉得这是不是就是一家日本的店。
或者说总部在日本的一个比较世界的唱片店。
嗯 对 然后但实际上tower records在日本的前20年。
他一共在日本发展了有40多年了。
他的前20年呢是一家属于美国总公司下面的这个日本分公司的形态。
就是那种典型的连锁企业。
嗯 然后那最初呢就是为什么tower records会在日本开分店。
就像我们刚才说的就是因为日本人对于世界金区有着非常高的消费欲望。
是的 然后在七几年的时候呢？
甚至北海道有一家就是唱片店的老板。
然后他看到美国有这么大一家tower records 封密美国。
然后他说我也要开一个。
他自己肯定也是这种世界音乐的爱好者。
对 因为那时候日本人就稍微挣些钱之后。
他当然想听就是更世界流行的那个音乐。
然后最新的金曲到底是什么？
所以那个时候日本人就需要等这个进口商去慢慢的把盘进进来。
然后但是进口商呢他不是唱片商。
所以进口商每回进进来的这个碟。
肯定不一定是最新的。
对 首先他不最新。
其实他拿的货不一定全。
对 而且他作为一个就是进口商。
他不是唱片商他就不那么懂音乐。
对 他可能选的这个品就不一定能够让这个老板感到对位。
对 所以像北海道这个老板他就是一个音乐发烧友。
他就说我要立志在日本开一间tower records一样的很好的选品店。
然后他的货源呢也不是那种从进口商那里来的。
有很多是这种小帽渠道。
就是可能是自己对小袋带进来的那个感觉。
那么在他这个店开了几年之后呢？
其实日本人也正式的去邀请美国tower records来日本开店了。
就是因为tower records自己的那个唱片渠道比较好。
离唱片商离歌手都非常近。
对 他一下就可以去拿到最新的谍。
然后他知道最流行的是什么拿到日本直接来卖。
那那个北海道的那家店怎么办呢？
可能很多人以为这个店会直接被起诉告到货产。
但实际上他在tower records正式成立日本分社之后呢？
就直接被收编成了一家官方的连锁店。
然后让这个北海道那家tower records的老板担任这个店的店长。
哇 那个老板不就美梦成真了。
对 然后tower records是一个对音乐发生了有特别友好的一个企业。
就感觉那个就获得了编制转动了。
而且是凭自己的努力。
嗯 对
这相同的故事其实有在我的故乡上演过你知道吗？
北京的80和90后百起码或者95前的人都会知道就是新街口。
是一个北京的有着各种各样的唱片店的一个街区。
然后当时真的有很多老板。
就是他自己也是音乐爱好者。
深度的音乐爱好者让他去开店。
当初彭蕾还拉着三轮板车在那边卖过子弹。
对 然后你看我从小就生活在那个地方。
然后但后来就突然有一天你就发现这一切都没了。
确实新街口都没有撑到那个唱片行业过去收编的。
对 就可能再撑一撑如果tower records想要就是开个中国北京分店的话。
一定会去新街口收编的。
嗯 对
所以我觉得这也是怎么说呢？
就是本人的一个人生巨大的遗憾。
那让我们讲回tower records好了。
好吧？
他在进入日本市场之后等于就开启了一个新一轮的内卷竞争。
因为之前的日本唱片商纷纷就干不过这么一个拥有渠道权的。
来自美国的唱片企业了。
嗯 是的
然后所以tower records最有代表性的所谓他这个店的特色的根基。
可能就是这种世界音乐世界金曲。
我觉得可能日本后来那个RMB发展案。
然后什么那个Hip-Hop 肯定都是很需要一家这样的店。
然后把最新的这些音乐风格带给他们才行。
是
然后所以后面他就慢慢的独立成为了一家日本的公司是吗？
就是说他脱离了这个美国总部的一个影响吗？
这个叫正好聊到今天的另外一个我就是重点。
就是说实体唱片这个东西。
因为你看像我们现在生活的2026年。
我们大家都会认为实体唱片是个摆设。
就是你可能更多的把它作为一个摆件去处理去看待。
然后当然这一切的原由就是因为在大概1012年的时候。
刘媒体音乐开始上线了。
而且我觉得这个刘媒体音乐其实是更能代表美国音乐的一个状态。
对
毕竟那个itunes Apple Music这种东西都是他们发明的吗？
就是刘媒体这个东西确实是美国人走的比较靠前。
但对应的就造成美国的实体唱片死的也会比较早。
对
然后在大概97 98年左右吧？
作为母公司的美国tower records。
它的盈利就开始不行。
甚至开始进行附属的这个形式了。
然后随着第一代iPhone发行。
然后itunes 刘媒体的这些平台在美国快速上线。
然后美国的唱片业迅速进入到了一个就是自由落体制的内卷当中。
基本上每年的销量比前一年不说腰斩也要跌掉起码20% 30%这么一个大数。
然后那为什么这个事情在日本没有发生。
这又是一个非常有趣的点。
就是日本人比较死闹金比较轴。
我觉得可能跟他们的产业有关系。
对
我记得特别清楚咱们小的时候其实一开始。
比如说家里的音响很多都是日本的牌子。
然后后来索尼的随身厅什么的CDG walkman等等。
包括日本人也更擅长做磁带。
就是他们在这些更实体的环节上是更垄断性的。
对
然后日本产业里一共有两条。
就是让他们在九几年的时候开始和美国的唱片行业发生了一些就是趋势上的不同。
或者说是巨大的反转。
首先你刚才说的日本是很擅长造这些各类音响设备。
有些消费电子的一个地方。
在日本有一条很奇怪的法律。
它是由设备商然后唱片的版权方以及消费者三方的业态共同构成的一个状态。
就是家庭使用版权的处理方式是什么样的。
简单来说就是比如我们在磁带时代。
大家可能很多人家里都曾经有过双卡录音机。
对
双卡磁带机
那你会发现如果你在左边塞一盘磁带右边塞一盘空白磁带。
你就可以转路吗？
对你自己在家轻松可以完成转路这个事情。
然后那么这个事情其实就涉及到版权的问题。
那比如在新街口是吧？
随便一个大哥就可以随便度。
我记得特别清楚
因为我爸就是一个小小发烧油。
就是你在新街口生活。
你很难逃得过买音响这件事。
然后我爸当时就是我们那胡同里面他最早买音响的。
然后当时我同学比如他们买了什么CD。
或者说买了磁带
我立刻就会去借过来。
然后我再刻一盘
我再转路一盘这样的一个模式。
对
然后像剑亚刚才说到的他童年的这个行为。
其实严格来说就是你在侵犯版权。
著作人的版权
然后但是这个行为。
但我没有传播
对
我也不会转卖
你又不可能禁止这个事情。
对吧？
然后你生产的设备。
比如你的双卡录音机又因为有这个功能。
所以受到大家的追捧。
是
所以日本人就在这里出了一个很日式的解决方案。
就是他会征收一笔家庭内做拷贝的这个税。
那这个税怎么征收呢？
那要是我要花在设备上吗？
没错
这就是日本人狡猾的日本骗机。
怪不得我爸买的音响九几年就好几千了。
对
尤其就比如说那种带播放器。
或者他有复制功能的这些设备。
到今天为止
就是你在日本如果单独买一个什么DVD播放器。
你会发现它可能价格很贵。
就是因为他们把一些需要补偿版权方的钱。
直接算进这个设备家里了。
你能读没关系
但是你能写这个东西一下就会有一些版权的东西在里面。
就会把价钱往上抬。
对
虽然法定规则是可能按1%。
就是整机价格的1%去征收。
但实际上它也会造成就是说这些东西在日本就会比较贵。
你在中国买一个比如带刻度功能的光驱。
什么的就会很便宜。
就会有这样的形式出现。
然后与此同时换来的就是敬雅的那种行为。
你在家里说你买一盘磁带。
然后你复刻一盘
然后你这一盘你也不是说拿去卖的。
你只是自己拿来听的。
所以日本就对这种家庭内的转路。
就是不去追就不去起诉它了。
但是它从设备上征收的。
它收了我钱
对 它会让设备制造商每年再去给音乐的版权方付一部分这个税钱。
你知道消费者还会付出一个事情。
就是如果你这个碟路多了转多了。
它会坏
确实 光驱和磁带的轴什么的。
反正最后全都被我搞坏了。
因为我是在
包括你看后来索尼他们出很高规格的磁带。
很高规格的CD什么的。
很多都是很适合用来转路去把音乐几乎无损的。
从原版复制到你的个人版上的。
对 然后所以这个是日本很不一样的一点。
因为有些国家它就会明令禁止家庭内的拷贝行为。
然后所以你看现在很多日本的碟。
你去放DVD前面最开始还是会有一个提示。
就是说本作品仅供你在家庭内观看使用。
意思就是说你复制了一份只在家庭内也是没有问题的。
不能牟利
对
然后那么刚刚讲的这是其中一个。
那还有另外一个很重要的更行业性一点的法规。
就是说日本有一个统一的这种音响制品。
尤其是CD的零售价的法律限定。
就比如说我们今天买一张单曲的DA。
那它出厂价格定好是1200日元。
然后那么日本的法律就规定。
无论你这张笛在哪里。
如果你是一个全新未拆封的状态去出售的一手盘。
那你都必须按照1200去做定件。
哦 就是不能有Sales。
对 但是日本人自己对这个事情也是觉得非常奇怪的。
就是他们甚至会专门写文章的时候。
一提到这个事就先批判一下。
说你这个法规违背了资本主义竞争的自由精神。
对 你这个对自由市场是一种侵犯。
对 因为按理说就是。
如果你是一个唱片商你的货出给唱片店之后。
唱片店爱卖多少是他自己的权利。
怎么他们这次好几只手了我这听着。
对 然后这个法规就是在日本一直就都存在。
然后最近的一次讨论好像是可能2001年还是什么时候。
反正这个法规过一阵就会被拿出来讨论一次。
但是每一次这个法规继续执行下去的原因。
都是说因为为了保护这个企划的多样性。
就是说日本的这个政府。
他的这个文化的管理部门就认为。
如果你可以自由竞争。
那就会造成赢者通知的局面。
就会造成最畅销的那个底也可能会被降价。
或者说只有他卖的特别好能挣钱。
其他人只要离开了唱片店。
就一下变成物质或变成三折货这样的去卖。
那比如除了大热歌手以外的那些歌手。
他就没人要了
就待会会被价格所趋势。
而不是说因为其实价格都是平等的。
我是因为音乐或者说这个音乐人而趋势。
我去购买了
对
所以这个日本人就觉得。
那我需要维持我个人本国的文化产业振兴的一个方案。
就是让我的这些音乐人出场设定好是什么价格。
那他未来一首永远是这个价格。
他不可以随便的进行大折。
所以他的原则就是音乐第一。
就是音乐人第一
文化繁荣第一
如果说为了文化繁荣。
他可以侵犯大家自由市场的这个技术。
他可以侵犯大家的钱包。
对
而不是卖出去第一。
他宁愿卖不出去
然后他就会造成比如这个碟压在我的仓库里。
其实他没有贬值
他只付出少量仓库成本。
他只要是新的
对
在唱片店里再卖呢？
他就卖这个价
他永远卖这个价
对
就比如Thor Records。
我觉得我10年卖掉200箱肯定没问题。
然后他所需要考虑的。
就是他的这个仓库成本。
他上面会标一个叫再贩售价格。
就必须按照那个定好的价格卖。
所以你这时候就会看到很多日本的这种。
大唱片店或者大商店。
就是比如有的巴西B Camera什么的。
他们的一些文化产品你甚至能捡到low。
就是因为比如这个店。
可能有一个10年前CD的部分。
他绝版了
他涨价是在二手市场上涨。
但是如果你是Thor Records。
你是有的巴西
你手里有一张10年前的这个碟。
你通过你的店的去到卖。
你只能卖1000元。
你不可以卖
你也不能涨
你不能涨价
也不能涨价
对
如果你单卖这个碟的话。
你就必须卖他的定价。
所以这就是日本人去想办法。
维持唱片也繁荣的一条法律性的东西。
在这里卡住了大家。
那另外当然这个法律还有附属的一部分。
他会说
如果你把他跟另外一些东西搭售的时候。
这个定价权就不按照CD。
作为一个纯文化产品定价了。
比如说我这张CD。
跟一件T-shirt作为一个saito。
去售卖的话
那他这个saito的定价权是自由的。
所以很多时候你会看到。
就是有一些这种CD的促销行为。
是跟这些商品捆绑在一起的。
买T恤送CD是类的。
当买T恤送CD的时候。
这个定价是由你商家个人自己就可以承担的。
但这个时候他还是需要再去售卖一个新的东西。
对
然后他们就认为这样去规定的话。
可以促进文化市场繁荣。
因为你等于去做周边了。
你就让这个比如音乐本身。
然后延续到了另外一种商品上面。
那你带来了更多的生产。
需求就业就可以不按之前的定价来了。
所以在日本我们前面讲的。
这两条法律的保护之下。
它的实体唱片就越做越繁荣。
嗯
因为活到今天
对
因为日本本土
尤其Tour Records是81年开的店。
然后在81年之后。
其实那一支是日本院很黄金的一个市集。
很多艺人都蹦出来了。
他们不停的发迪
但是反观美国那边。
它是这样
它是没有这种法律保护的。
就导致比如唱片商。
我今天给比如Michael Jackson。
我给Michael出一张心理。
然后但是我不小心印多了。
他也得打折
而且他打折会到什么地方销售。
沃尔玛会把它卖去。
所以这个时候
在九几年的时候
等于美国的实体唱片。
也同时受到了沃尔玛这种仓储零售。
对
大声超的冲击
另外一方面受到了来自苹果这种。
对
这种流媒体平台的冲击。
所以它死得格外之快。
对
因为我记得咱们小时候。
大概高中的时候
就突然间所有人都用上了。
Apple Nano。
Apple的
Saffle
就是那些MP3东西就来了。
Classic
对
然后一下就大家不听CD了。
然后如果你这个时候。
你要买一张CD
你把那个里面的歌。
考备到i2ins里。
是很麻烦的一件事情。
对
你还要拥有一个苹果电脑吗？
然后这个转化是一个巨恶性的事情。
然后那个时候也是互联网倒版。
和这种各种资源网站。
爆炸的时候
蓬勃发展的一个时期。
对
就是混沌时代
就因为那个时候实体的唱片。
这些CD、DVD的销售一下都被。
干到一个很离谱的死亡的状态了。
对
直到突然有一天
就全部都是流媒体了。
对
然后所以在进入到千禧年之后。
Thoracus的母公司就连年负债。
然后接近破产的一个状态。
然后那么这个时候。
日本的Thoracus反而每年都是维持在盈利的。
甚至是一个健康盈利的这么一个状态。
通过严苛的法律法规。
对
以及对于消费者的压榨。
然后保护了日本的这些唱片店。
就是说你要为你的热爱付费。
对
你要为你的热爱买单。
文化需要大家花钱来支持。
这就是他们日本人的一个默许。
我觉得直到今天可能也是这样的。
对
然后所以在这之后。
就是日本Thoracus在大概002年的时候。
就开始启动了当时非常流行的一个。
自我收购的这么一个提案。
他要去跟美国Thoracus说。
说我们去找一些外部的资金。
然后我们自己也管理层。
然后所持有的股权和我们的这些盈利什么的。
做一个属身的这么一个筹码。
然后就让Thoracus。
Japan独立出来成为一家日本公司。
所以Thoracus在零几年那个时候。
就是大概002 2003年最终谈妥了。
这个收购案
说如何从美国这边属身。
因为美国Thoracus这个时候。
他也是向我们最初讲的。
他不会为难就是北海道那个店主一样。
对
他也不会为难日本Thoracus。
从自己这里独立出去。
因为如果美国的那个。
比如说创始人
他肯定也很热爱音乐。
对
音乐这个事我觉得可能和做其他的企业。
还是有点不一样的。
肯定是希望这个事情能继续下去的吗？
对
当时这个收购还是完成的比较顺利的。
就是因为各方人员在回忆录里都说。
这个东西可能没有太费劲。
母公司就觉得你们还是应该活着。
我们美国死了就死了。
你可以在日本作为独立的Thoracus活下去。
就等于说母公司不再成为日本power records的累赘了。
然后日本的Thoracus他们就自负云亏。
对
成为一家独立公司了。
所以这就是日本战后。
我觉得是很难得的一个很奇怪的。
日本公司从美国公司里独立出来。
对
独立主权的感觉
然后刚刚讲过了Thoracus成功赎身。
以及他前身为什么是一家这么世界的公司。
然后我们继续先往下再下一层。
从刚刚的7楼的世界金曲大集合。
来到6楼也是Thoracus的非常灵魂的一个业务。
灵魂很so music。
然后那么到6层其实他甚至有自己独立的一个名字。
叫Thorvinyl。
嗯
那这一层就是专门卖Lecordo。
就是各种黑胶的那一层。
对
然后他会说就是在喜布亚这个店里。
大概有10万张黑胶在这里。
然后同时他不仅有新品黑胶。
而且更有4 5万张的中古黑胶放在这里卖。
所以你在这一层会享受到整栋楼里最好的音响。
以及最爽的逃跌的那个过程。
是
因为他会按字母表。
然后按照日本的还是海外的。
然后就给你把这个黑胶全部排好。
然后放在大牌的货架上。
然后他的音响系统。
大家可以稍微听一下。
就是能感觉到这个层的音响。
相比西龙
对
会更加的通透
然后各个品段更加的饱满充实一点。
这就是因为他们用了一套影院的那个号角系统。
对
当然我们把图放在收脑子里。
大家看了就知道了。
对
这一层用了应该是整栋楼里最好的音响。
给大家去放黑胶时代的音乐。
你也能在我们录到的环境音领。
然后听到那种Analog那种模拟信号的那个质感。
是
然后很多那种特别经典的绝版的黑胶。
你就可以去找
然后可能很多人会觉得这家店。
它找黑胶的就是陶蝶的丰富度。
不如一些小店
但是这个我觉得也是属于Tour Records的一个情怀。
就是因为这个黑胶业务。
也是他们最早的业务的构成。
因为他们刚进日本的时候。
其实主要销售的还是黑胶和卡带。
对
然后之后才慢慢走到CD。
所以6和7楼
其实我觉得你从历史上可以看到。
它就像Tour Records的灵魂的起点一样。
然后我就记得当时我们去6楼的时候。
首先它那个电梯旁边就放了一个巨大的绿洲的海报。
对
因为绿洲好像这两年在日本开演场会开挺多的。
而且他们在日本拥有巨大的阅密群体。
然后6楼你一往里走。
就又是一个绿洲的一个专区。
然后他在售卖他们这个25周年的一套盘。
然后那个盘一看就是特别的珍贵。
就值得收藏的那种。
然后就而且卖真的挺贵的。
我拿起来一套
我记得是2万多日元。
然后在这一层甚至他们还准备了一个喝啤酒的bar。
一个beer bar在那。
确实就是喝啤酒和听黑胶也非常的融合。
对
然后它是26年2月底也才最新在那开的这么一个conert。
这是不借鉴的那个惠比寿的blue note。
我觉得可能日本人从很早之前就喜欢把酒吧和音乐这两个东西。
坎榜在一块卖
很妙
然后我记得6楼还有一堆就是卖海报的。
就是音乐海报的一个区域。
然后那个海报都是很大幅的。
可能aer那么大。
然后它就是装框装好了甚至在那展示着。
像家具成立你看那个挂在那的窗户或者门板。
你可以先开了一张一张的去找它。
对
然后就是你在逛那个tower records的时候。
你真的可以去留意一下它的一些边边小角。
就尤其是上方啊？
它可能在某个架子上就会pa一个会挂一个海报。
然后这个海报上面它就会标价。
就比如说我之前就看到有一个海报上面它就标了3000多日元。
那你肯定就是可以去购买的。
对
然后如果你认真找一下你会发现在卖海报的那个柜台那儿。
有一个本你可以去翻。
然后它是它的产品目录。
对
然后而且好像是每个每张的价格是不一样的。
这些好像都是那个vintage海报。
就总之是tower records可能无论是solo还是自己攒下来这么多年。
它都是那种很精品。
你要是真的是某个乐队的海报你逃找了还是挺喜欢的。
对
以前心结口也有
心结口真的这么繁荣吗？
当然
好那么让我们再看完了最经典的这两层之后。
我们就顺着日本音乐的流行史来到下面的五层。
我觉得五层大家可能猜不到会是什么东西。
所以我们来先记忆的五层的氛围。
让大家感受一下这个空间里的声音。
对
大家可能一下感觉跟六楼的氛围发生了一个巨大的转变。
突然就K起来了
对
然后这里就是日本最大规模的kpop floor。
这一层我记得就是一走进去就是一个拍利德展示区。
对
类似于小展示墙吧？
然后它会把所有的它有的kpop明星来这个店里面做活动室拍的这个拍利德。
还是宽幅的呢？
还是签名板的很多。
对
很多是签名板还写了日期什么的。
嗯
然后全部展示在这里。
当时看到了有东方神奇。
然后这里其实就很像一个现代一点的那个追星的布置了。
就是上面两层你感觉是那个古早唱片店或者说那个经典唱片店会有的样子。
到这一层你就会看到很多什么人型的立板啊？
然后很多打歌相关的这个装饰啊都会在附近在这一层里面摆着。
这个我就是也来到了一个很有趣的话题啊？
就是尤其如果大家这样面经常看红白歌会的话。
就会觉得说kpop对日本音乐的统治力是越来越高了。
是
嗯
然后包括日本自己的团也越来越kpop了。
嗯对
我觉得从这长好就可以顺着那个刚才我们讲的那个tour records的历史接着往下讲。
就是从大概2010年左右日本唱片行业终究还是开始受到了流媒体的冲击。
对
然后所以这个时候就是实体唱片究竟靠什么拯救呢？
就要开始靠偶像这个东西来拯救了。
这个时候呢基本是kpop在日本大范围流行下来的那个起源一点的时间点。
因为它开始占据了那个销量很重要的位置。
虽然说kpop这一层里面的叠明显没有上面那几层多啊？
但是因为它是一个独特的群体。
而且是非常重要且庞大的一个群体。
所以就是非常值得但另一层出来。
嗯对这个问题我也是跟那个Tony聊的时候。
他也说确实就像你们中国人色了解的我们日本年轻人喜欢kpop。
对就是喜欢kpop。
你那个理发师他都已经是中年人了。
但是他说现在的年轻人确实也是kpop。
然后他自己也会听kpop。
就是说可能这个东西在日本的听众那里还是确实很有时常。
对好那让我们接着向下走来到四层。
然后四层是来到了一个非常有日本特色的楼层。
他主要卖的呢是ami媒和game主题的这个music。
啊这层就是外国人很多。
嗯对就是你们看到的外国人基本都会在这层拿点东西走。
对对对我觉得也是会吸引外国人喜欢日本文化。
喜欢日本流行音乐的一个特别重要的一层。
动画和游戏有二次元相关的这些文化。
他其实就是日本流行音乐的一个出口。
哦对就上面kpop那里是那个进入口。
就是那个贸易逆差的那部分。
然后到了ami媒和game这里就是贸易逆差的那部分。
是是如果看那个别的数量还有就是每一层的人流量来讲。
感觉他们还是挺出口导向性的一个照片店啊？
确实啊因为到了日本这一层确实那个外国人很多。
嗯对然后呃我们去的那天那个C位上摆的还是电铸人系列的那个音乐。
旁边一个板子上面都是很经典的那个动画的音乐。
就我记得有那个星际牛仔。
嗯像攻击郡的一些音乐啊什么都会在。
嗯对这段我作为老二虽然可以给大家科普一下啊？
其实anime就是anison就是anime song。
嗯然后就是在日本那边就是anison。
然后anison这个东西其实在零几年的时候啊？
我们招号接前面历史那一段就是在零一零二年的时候。
其实还是一个稍微哈斯卡西一点的音乐分类。
修饰一点对就是如果你这个人听歌只听anison类的话。
你一定是个死宅你很阴暗你戴个眼镜。
然后穿个破T恤的那个胖子。
对就是大家会有一种刻板印象。
对会有刻板印象包括就是听这个东西的人。
像我我们都会觉得这东西有点丢人。
就是你不好意思说我没有那么主流。
对然后但是后来就是我觉得也是随着就是唱片业自己吧？
确实感受到了压力。
其实从零几年开始。
jpop就开始尝试和anime这个东西进行深度的捆绑。
然后像那个时候最著名的一个案例是那个。
那时候激动战士高达的最新的系列一共两级一百级。
然后中间请了很多很多的jpop非常有感染力的新人歌手。
或者是已经成名的歌手。
然后去为他唱那种那个年代很流行电子无趣风的那个音乐。
然后他们当时做动画的立案目标就是。
让大家听到歌就一定能想到动画的名场面。
然后让大家看动画一定会对这个歌非常的上头。
然后于是从那个时候开始。
就说我们这些老二层就感觉到好像可以站出来做人了。
又没有那么的羞耻了。
对可以可以可以出来光天化日的见一见人了。
然后包括我觉得eva的那个歌也是越来越主流嘛？
对你想那个她请宇德天光去给新剧场满唱歌也是06年的时候嘛？
对其实06年离现在已经20年来。
就是那个时候慢慢的开始说越来越多的大牌歌手主流歌手。
开始会带着自己那种很主流的jpop曲风。
然后进入到安妮美的行活里面去。
然后安妮美音乐就开始慢慢的从小众的一个不上台面的东西转向大众了。
对而且就是我觉得日本的动画确实也是越来越主流一点嘛？
对也是从黄金期开始嘛？
日本动画可能八九十年代特别有钱的时候。
他才开始有自信说我去找那个jrock的一些小众的乐队去先合作一下。
然后慢慢到现在大家能看到日本在世界上最流行的jpop全部是跟安妮美绑在一起的。
然后包括像九十让对吧和攻击俊的这个这么多年的捆绑。
然后他也让jpop或是anime的音乐然后走向了古典乐。
对走向了音乐厅
对那个时候特别流行在那个。
音乐厅
现场演奏会嘛？
对因为从那个时候开始攻击俊和安妮俊这对师徒就特别喜欢。
让自己的作品里头首先用交响乐去配。
用很多古典乐的元素。
然后其次他们在动画火了之后还会在专门的开动画音乐会。
甚至中国刚才说那时候有一支也很流行开九十让的演唱会嘛？
很多也都没有授权那是票卖的特别好。
对对
所以anime音乐这个东西其实到现在已经成为jpop一个不可分割的一部分了。
是然后包括你刚刚说到高达嘛？
然后像最新的那个我们之前在东京看电影看那个。
上光的哈萨威对
他的那个op就是开场的那首歌就买了snooze。
snooze
sada的snooze那个snooze是拿过格莱美的单曲对。
然后哈萨威的那个片尾还是买的那个枪花的那个另外一首摇滚歌曲。
对就是他们甚至都可以直接去买了。
对就是日本动画界其实特别喜欢买欧美的摇滚音乐过去当自己的那个主题曲。
对然后包括电铁人也是就是行米金悬石还有一朵电光去唱。
嗯对然后所以就是anime放在四层属于站起来的标志。
就是我每回我每回去逛这层的时候就有万千感慨。
因为我在这层里还是能找到很多就是你童年的记忆的对。
你童年的消费
哈哈哈哈对就是会觉得啊这个童年消费的这么一个东西终于。
终于就是站上排面了。
嗯而且他放在中间确实我觉得就是有一种乘上起下的感觉。
嗯对好那说到起下。
嗯我们就来到三楼。
三楼来到了jpop的这个主力区。
嗯就是前面中间家的4563层楼吧？
它其实在盘的那个数量上感觉还是相对有点稀少的。
然后但是到了三层jpop虽然面积一样。
但是它的货架思路就是给你塞爆。
就是全部塞满
然后这个才是现在jpop不会是唱片业的一个主力军吧？
嗯对这个就是于就是日本国内大市场的那个感觉了嘛？
就是他们的偶像团体。
不只是偶像团体就是从流行歌手然后到偶像团体。
然后到就是所有你能想到的只要是这个人是个日本人。
然后他在搞音乐对然后基本在jpop这层都会被归类到这里面。
嗯然后这一层我觉得对于那些特别喜欢比如说日本City Pop。
然后好多现在当红的日本歌手的朋友。
你就可以去按照他那个他是按照评价名吗去排序的。
然后当然他也会把最火的那些就是打热的时候。
对放在最外面有单独自己的一个小伙伽。
然后你就可以去找你想要的那个歌手嘛？
然后去看他的底颜什么的对在这一层其实我觉得可能是。
作为喜欢日本文化的观众吧是最推荐带来去逛的一层。
因为他不仅会有就是这些歌手的底颜。
然后你还会看到tour record的自己出的一些精神曲。
就比如对于city pop他会有自己的一个city pop合集的这么一个光盘在发售。
哦这个是就是塔电自己出品的对就是属于他自己手脱的对他手脱的。
但是他可能做了选举的工作。
对所以他把自己喜欢的city pop歌单给做成了底颜。
然后作为商品在这里发售然后他去弹好版权这样。
我我记得他们可能每隔一段时间他就会有一个主推的一个小专题。
然后比如说像什么大龙泳衣啊就是这种。
然后他就会把他的比如说多少周年的叠或者说最经典的那个叠放在一个区域里。
然后因为他比较重要的这些音乐他都会给你视听的。
然后你就可以站在那个播放机前然后戴上耳机。
然后一点一点去听这些音乐选出你自己喜欢的。
然后我记得我之前就特别喜欢在这一层去听他。
就是刚才海鲁说的那种合集嘛？
因为那种合集真的比如说我可能不是从那个年代开始就追日本city pop的人。
然后我是需要听一些合集然后一点一点去选择我喜欢的这个音乐人和歌的。
然后这种合集对我来讲就特别的重要。
而且这种合集你是不可能在apple music上面或什么qq音乐上面去找到的。
因为我当时我有试过说我看看apple music上面有没有这样的专辑。
然后说没有完全没有。
对这个就确实你说到一个特别经典的日式行为。
就是日本唱片店能称过刘媒体有一个特别重要的点。
就是他们很多的艺术家在刘媒体最初的时候是不接受上刘媒体的。
对他就不上他不会搬过去。
好像是杰尼斯旗下的艺人。
然后还有阿拉西好像也不放。
对就是阿拉西好像确定是一开始好几年不上刘媒体。
然后所以就就就这个东西也是日本的一个特色吧？
你会看到很多日本限定。
是像我之前买的那一张他基本上就是那种一人一手成名曲的那种歌。
然后很多首可能真的我觉得太好听了。
而且非常小众可能我去油管上面去找都很难找到mv的这种歌。
但是他非常的能够代表日本的cdpub的这种音乐。
他可能每个专辑他会有一个主题。
我记得我之前就买过一个tokio主题的。
对我就很喜欢这个音乐。
然后在家里面干活什么打扫卫生的时候我就会去循环播放他。
对总之这个也挺神的就是三层和四层吧？
基本就是日本现代音乐的主要的支柱嘛？
然后他们也基本上帮日本唱片业活下来的那个核心。
就比如说四层我们刚才除了说到那个anime和那个game以外。
其实有一部分的idol的那个音乐也是放在四层出卖的。
小偶像的音乐
对小偶像音乐放在那儿。
然后如果这个偶像稍微大一点。
他有可能有一部分是放在三层卖的。
对然后所以就是偶像音乐其实在在2011年开始对日本音乐影响很大嘛？
我去翻那个日本唱片销量排行榜。
然后基本上中间大家觉得这个比如米金悬施王牛这些新生代的。
这个日本音乐人还没撑起来。
有sob什么的没出现的时候全部是靠AKB和阿拉希两家。
把日本唱片店靠握手卷这个东西给盘火的。
是韩耐姆版什么的对对。
那个时候秋元康发明的这个商法真的也是钻日本那个法律的。
成功割到了你这一代与少年。
对因为其实那个年代就是日音。
他说到底还是稍微平几一点。
就比如说他容易出现情况不接的中间几年。
然后你就会发现可能从11年到15年。
这五年间是绝对的被偶像产业所统治的五年。
就是你甚至很难在专辑销售榜上找到特别厉害的。
那个大家都喜欢的J-POP明星入榜。
这也是怎么说呢就是tour record不仅要熬过。
前面就是独立出来的全球唱片业的浪潮。
然后在日本他也给靠这些小偶像。
然后卖低也把自己活下来。
就是让大家在实体这一块持续的未来发电。
对然后所以从那个时候开始。
其实像日本的唱片店或者说尤其是tour record。
就养成了一个习惯。
就是说一定要搞点这种就是搞点事。
对搞点事情搞点现象活动方便大家卖蝶。
就蝶他已经不仅仅是一张蝶了。
不是说你就是为了听音乐。
对一定有一些其他的附加。
对像到现在为止日本人都就是严格的继承了这个东西。
就比如说现在如果你去买蝶他里面送的。
可能不是当初握手券。
因为当初那个是你买偶像的蝶。
你就可以去握握手握十秒还是十五秒。
然后买100张呢？
买100张你都可以买100张对应的那个时间。
然后去元康还会搞投票。
就是说我这个48个偶像谁占C位。
你去买专辑然后里头有投票券。
然后所以握手券和投票券这个东西呢？
就是他发明的对他发明的。
然后到现在呢一部分被偶像产业继承了。
一部分呢到了就是抽选。
就是现在日本抽选很大程度上要依赖蝶里面送的那张券。
对比如说我们三两年在日本看的所有演出。
都是因为我们买了那个蝶。
然后里面有抽选券。
然后我们抽到了一个票。
就比如说日本演唱会现在的开票周期。
可能要提前半年甚至提前一年都有。
好嘛？
然后投三个月要不是粉丝俱乐部。
要不是买蝶的人可以抽。
然后有的时候你还可以在之后的三个月抽第二轮。
那一般发售可能是最后拖在演唱会开始前的一两个月。
然后如果还有胜票没被抽完的话。
会再放一部分门票给一般的公众。
然后那这时候如果你作为一个音乐的粉丝。
其实你很难拒绝去买一张你喜欢的这个歌手的专辑或者单曲。
对而且他往往这个专辑还是一个限定盘。
对日本人是全世界最喜欢出限定盘的一个地方。
大家如果熟悉的话知道他会有出汇生产限定。
有期间生产限定
然后有那个就是限时复刻的那种盘。
对还中年限定
然后他的这些限定盘呢？
就哪怕你买普通盘你在首发的时候还会有出汇特点。
对对对
然后你还会有店头特点。
就是说不仅是唱片商奖励你作为第一批早鸟。
对够实货的
对然后去去买给你一些赠品。
然后同时呢这个唱片店也会说我这有我店内专属的赠品送完为止。
就是日本人在实体唱片营销的这个商华上真的是极大的促进了他们周边产业的繁荣。
是就我们上个月买了网牛的那一套新的专辑。
单曲
单曲都还不是专辑。
对就是他这个碟里大家可以理解。
他这碟里就一首歌最多两首歌可能。
但是呢因为我买的是两个出汇生产限定的版本。
所以其中呢有一个虽然是一张碟里面只有一首歌。
但是呢他有一个巨大的像黑胶一样大的风套。
而且是对开始的风套就很漂亮是一个非常漂亮的出版物印刷品。
对你可以买回来做收藏的那个东西。
然后你想你单买一张海报还要三千日元呢？
我这个连叠带海报一起才三千多一点人值啊？
然后另外一张呢他虽然是一张CD里只有一首歌嘛？
但是呢他同时还送了一张地为地。
是这个乐队之前某一次巡演的整场的录像。
然后所以就是你说这个钱很容易就花出去了。
然后你获得这个抽选券之后。
你就可以在限定的时间去抽他们的演唱会门票。
门票不是免费的是购买演唱会门票的资格。
对然后但是他演唱会门票反而就做得更便宜点嘛？
他把演唱会的一部分钱其实花在了这个实体长边上嘛？
然后就让这个实体长边也能活着。
对就因为实体长边和演唱会可能对于歌手来说。
他们算算收入差不多。
然后但是你作为消费者算算差不太多。
但是你多获得了这样的东西你就就觉得自己很赚嘛？
对对对
然后我记得这一层还有二手跌的。
就大家不要以为塔电纸卖新专辑。
我记得当时也是在三楼吧？
然后最靠前的那个位置。
他整个一面墙都是Use的CD。
然后也是好多老外就扎在那儿找。
然后像版本龙衣什么米金悬师。
各种就是新业员等等比较当红流行的。
你都能低价买到
这个我觉得那边的低价是因为日本人对二手品的。
那个要求是近乎苛刻的变态。
就比如大家都知道如果你买一张专辑CD的话。
他会分这么几个东西。
首先是最外头有一层塑料封皮。
然后塑料封皮上有时候会贴贴纸。
然后打开了之后在靠近就是输的书籍。
类似于光盘的转轴那部分。
有时候会称一张纸。
就是小书条给你小书籤似的特小。
对然后那个条也是这个专辑的一部分。
也是折价的一部分。
对上面其实会印标题。
然后还会印专辑的一些销售信息。
然后它的出版物码出版物编号什么的都在上面。
然后发售时间发售价格很多印内条上。
然后你再打开之后还有歌词本。
然后歌词本完后还有这个碟本身上头有没有划痕。
皮线好不好什么的。
但可能咱们一般就是只注重这个盘能不能听。
对如果你是为了买那张盘去的。
你就买那个没有条或者歌词本窝窝的超级便宜。
可能三五百日元对五六百日元就能买到一张。
就是如果你去旁边买新的。
新的要那个元件
对可能没有三千也要一千五六或者一千二三。
你等于一下就半价去买一个体验一样的点嘛？
所以就这部分的二手还是挺爽的。
是而且大家就会抢你知道吗？
我那次就是逛的时候。
我旁边明显有一个白人。
他想跟我一块抢那个版本龙衣。
然后我这个时候我就看准了。
我就全都拿走
就是确实逃二手跌真的特别有乐趣。
对然后就是你每一次去。
你可能就会知道更多的音乐。
你就会了解更多的专辑和音乐人。
然后你下一次再去的时候。
你跟洋人抢的时候你就更加温准狠。
对你知道那张专辑。
哎呀这这洋人一看是个菜牛。
他就抢那个最流行的不抢那个最好的。
对对对对
然后我整合讲到这我想给大家克服一下。
就是去日本逃跌这个事情。
就是我们虽然讲到Tower Records里面有两层。
只要是三层和六层有二手的CD和黑胶嘛？
但实际上可能大家如果去网上看帖子。
很多人会说Tower Records尤其是喜悲亚店。
逃二手跌特别不值。
然后有的甚至还不是代购或者你去买新跌什么的。
这个就是因为日本其实还有几家唱编行。
大家的市场定位会有点不一样。
除了Tower Records的以外。
还有另外两家比较大的唱编行。
分别是H&MV和Union Disc。
然后那这两家H&MV跟Tower Records一样。
其实都是外国唱编行开去日本的分公司。
然后但是H&MV Japan之后是被罗森集团收购掉了。
然后他变成了罗森。
就是因为罗森其实他掌握了日本一部分的票务系统。
票务系统和演出系统。
然后所以他把H&MV收进来也是为了把他搭售。
然后做一些相关的这些合作。
他就是业务运行比较顺畅。
他不像Tower Records他是一个专门卖碟的店。
他在罗森那边定位就有点改变了。
虽然他之前也是一个英国唱片公司唱片店的日本分公司。
但是他现在不是独立形态吗？
那另外一家Union Disc他自己是独立的日本的唱编行。
然后他是在七几年的时候从他的日本母公司独立出来的。
他的日本母公司一开始做过一段音响设备。
然后所以他们就想我既然卖音响了我也要卖碟。
后来这个碟店自己独立出来成为一家。
专门在日本做二手碟店生意的店。
所以其实如果你在日本想淘二手碟的话。
就是你愿意花整天时间去淘二手碟。
可能去Union Disc这个唱片会比较方便一点。
然后Union Disc有一个很大的特征。
就是他每家店会有自己的主题。
就比如他在新宿店就有招合民谣主题的本店里面全是招合民谣。
然后在西伯亚的Union Disc是主带Club音乐的。
大家会在很多说唱或是其他人听到的。
就是他们对Club音乐非常着迷的Club。
我记得中叶是不是有一家。
对中叶也有一家
但是中叶那家就不是带副标题的那种店。
然后但是比如新宿他就会有专门的anime和gaming音乐的那个店。
而且我感觉就是往往Tower Records附近也会跟着那两家。
反正不是有个H&MV就会有一个Union Disc。
对因为Union Disc尤其它是制作中物店。
它甚至做到了说从英美那边批发中物的当垃圾输进来。
然后再去分类卖
它就是日本最大的二手碟流通商。
Tower Records就作为一个活动商。
就是它附近一定能聚集很多愿意为音乐活动跑线下。
参与活动参与签售这些各种各样活动的人。
然后H&MV它就更像是一个怎么说的。
就是跟演出相关的东西。
Beams
然后Beams它一直没有独立过。
就是它前面三家唱片店有两家是独立状态的。
然后Beams其实一直是有一个自己的选品线。
就是Beams叫Record还是。
对我记得元素是有一家单独的门店的。
对然后但是它并不是把自己作为一个唱片店去认知的。
它给自己的定位还是一个音乐选品店的感觉。
对元素那边有一家专门卖黑胶碟的那个。
对然后你也可以听。
然后它里面会摆着那个黑胶的音响什么的都挺高级的。
对然后你会发现它的选品可能更偏就是潮流流行一点。
就是那种质量又很高。
但又小众的灵兵这种东西。
就会在那里使他们的主推项目。
对对对然后好像还有一个二手的电视布克奥夫里面也会有吧？
对但是布克奥夫里面就更像是日本人把自己家里没用的。
所有东西都直接往那一共拿大手包。
收来什么它就卖什么那种。
对它没有那么强的选品的性质。
对那就比如你去布克奥夫你可能能捡到就是那种便宜的漏。
但是你捡到漏的这个概率很小。
你去Union Disc你能非常就是相对稳定的捡到一些你喜欢歌手的二手牌。
对对对对因为它毕竟走量是日本最大的二手电流通商吗？
我觉得三楼四楼对于喜欢日本音乐J-POP的人来讲。
就是基本上你每次都会满载而归。
然后像我们那天逛的时候也去鞋帐买了很多铁。
然后它会赠送你一些免费的小贴纸啊什么的。
对你要记得自己拿。
因为它有的时候会写好说你可以拿一枚走自由的。
然后那个就在收音台旁边。
然后我记得那天他那个收音台的上方还会有那个电视吗？
然后正在放那个雨多天光的那个Science Fiction的演唱会的那个蓝光的那个影像。
这整个感觉超爽
对基本上那个空间里所有墙面都会被那个屏幕或者海报占据掉。
对然后它还会每一层都会放自己的这个推荐的音乐。
对然后推荐的这个音乐就是有一块屏幕显示说Now Playing是什么？
然后这个推荐都是他们的电源自己来推荐的。
哦那说到这里确实我觉得就是Tower Record的很大的一个魅力就是它的这个套推荐系统。
因为它每家店就是你都能在店头看到不同的电源手写的说我推荐这个碟。
然后他有一些主推的会把推荐理由用那个收卸小卡片的形式写好然后放在那里。
然后其实每家店电源喜欢推的东西也不太一样。
然后呢除此之外呢你在买一些碟子的时候可能还能看到上面。
会有一个小小的红标签贴着Utsusume。
也是他们推荐过的那个也是另外一种它的选品系统的展现形式。
就比如米金悬施的五张碟里它可能会给其中两张贴Utsusume。
然后确实那两张是最好听最值得你专举形式买回来的两张。
对我记得我们那次就是听到了一个我真的完全没有听说过的一个音乐。
然后那个专辑包括那个歌手是谁我完全不知道。
然后他在那个屏幕上面显示的那个now playing。
一看就是电源自己手写手绘的这种推荐语在上面。
然后同时你在伴随着现场收听到的这个音乐。
你要不然就是想去浏规题上去找一下。
要不然你就想立刻把这张专辑找到买下来。
对总之这个发现的体验真的是太爽了。
这个也是我觉得现在很推荐大家去total record的一个原因。
就是它的这套推荐系统是广泛存在于每个电源器。
一定能让你感觉有所收获还有体验的一个事情。
对因为他的这种推荐一定是某个人或某些人他在弄的。
对他自己的音乐品味然后他对他喜欢的这个歌手听了很多了。
他才会推荐给你像现在就是流媒体推荐的算法。
他只会把你听过的类似的东西或者就是他猜你喜欢什么？
但实际上就是每个人对音乐的品味可能都是杂识性的。
不会有人只听一个风格的音乐的。
对然后就像我们之前那一期去讲什么我听的书一样。
就是说算法或者说AI给你推荐的这些书单和这个店主。
他自己读了那么多书他开店开了这么多年给你推荐和摆出来的书夹的样子。
结果一定是不一样的他背后的这个人的意志是最有魅力的部分。
对而且他那个观点的逻辑到底在哪里。
也就是说哪张笔他虽然数据好但他音乐性可能没有那么棒。
因为你只要走到这一层你听到耳边响起的这个音乐。
你所带的一个潜意识就是知道说有一个人在给我放呢？
是这个店的店员或者店长他选的歌这个人真有意思。
或者说我这个人选了我听过的一首歌他太有品了。
或者说他选了一个我完全没有听过的一首歌好厉害。
对就是你一定是影响了一个对于真实的人的一个联想。
然后那他的推荐对你的影响也会更深。
对甚至大家如果敢于挑战的话。
我就是可以去你看那个店员正在弄架子。
你就问他一下吗？
对然后你能问他这个歌手你就是推荐什么？
然后tour record他有一个就是内部招聘的规则。
就是他很喜欢招那个经常去他店里买蝶的人。
然后去他那打工或者去他那当正式员工对。
然后很多tour records店的店长都是什么学生时代就经常出这家唱片店的。
就是资深阅谜对然后他们特别喜欢招这些资深阅谜做员工。
因为他们的那个很多这个企业顶层的负责人也都是资深阅谜。
甚至他们的就是日本tour record的那个老板他是学音乐出身的。
他后来才去学的工商管理。
他是经营了tour record之后他才补的工商管理课。
他之前完全就是个音乐系出来的人。
我们新街口也有很多这种人才。
确实就是你要这么说新街口的那个音乐业态。
就是他具体的比日本还要密集。
对我们当年我们新街口真的就是不仅有低厅对。
有节节然后还有各种比如有紫代店。
有live house有唱片店对然后还有少年工就是学音乐的地方。
对然后还有各种乐器店然后还有专业的录音室。
还有卖音响的对对对还有饭子。
对对满街大哥把那个大衣掀开。
根本要点嘛就是那个倒板的正版的倒板咱都有。
对然后包括就是受众群体也非常之多嘛？
因为那边学校很多就年轻人很多。
然后中年人也喜欢音乐。
可惜就是没有等到一个好的时代吧？
你看toral record他带领了这么大的一个线下的相关的产业。
也好活动也好他提供了好多的就业。
你像我小时候我的梦想就是比如打工的阶段。
我能在一家唱片店里面。
有家附近的唱片店里面去打工太幸福了。
就确实啊就是唱片店打工这个让我外发电动可以。
总之确实就是他这个业态的理念不太一样。
然后你看像在往下面走toral record的二层。
他就是一个咖啡店主题咖啡店算是。
他有的时候会在里面搞一些活动。
然后有的时候甚至就是如果这个团体比较火。
他联名的IP比较火那就是完全预约制的。
你必须提前约好了才能进去消费和咖啡感受这个主题的氛围。
或者会有消费箱在里面做见面会什么的。
但是如果你平时比如你光泪了。
你想休息一下喝杯咖啡也行。
嗯对他这个设计还挺好的。
对当然二层哪怕是咖啡厅也是放着非常大声的这个音乐。
大家也可以听一下。
从二层走到一楼呢其实就走到了一个算是跟街面上相通的一个空间了。
就是最唱销的那个一层。
嗯对都是那种怎么说呢就跟推荐的关联小一点。
但是真的是每个人都卖爆了的金曲会一直在这放。
然后会有好几个架子。
台柱子对就是那个各个台都押照出场的对。
上面那些层每个层选个代表出来。
对对对有的人一个人能代表两个层的那种。
在一楼其实你也能看到好多外国人。
就是他可能是有客门一下被吸引进来。
然后发现了诸董马尔斯或者雷迪嘎嘎竟然发了一个日本特别的对。
就很值得买对日本唱片界好像还有一个习俗。
就是那个给欧美明星发日本国内版的碟的时候会多要一首bonus。
对就是日本线令牌里面可能会比他的其他的版本要多一首歌之类的。
就永远让你有了一种你买的不亏。
但他也赚了的感觉对因为这些年可能比如说欧美的歌手。
他也会稍微做一些曲格。
就比如说Harris Delce他可能有媒体上他这转欧达比方。
他这个专辑可能一共是一首歌。
但是他流媒体上会有一首歌是挥的。
就你听不了就必须买迪。
你必须买迪就跟日本人学坏了是吗？
嗯对我不知道
就是他们也在想一些挽救自己唱片业的方法。
对我以为他们完全不在乎呢？
而且现在就是很多欧美的音乐人他们在黑椒这一块花样也很多嘛？
哦对黑椒好像现在已经每年出回来有10亿美元的规模了。
就是黑椒在在逐年增长是实体唱片里增长最快的一个品类。
对所以我觉得就是说实体唱片他不是非得死。
他只是那个十年或者十几二十年的时候。
大家可能喜欢一个新鲜的玩意儿。
但是如果说你从欣赏音乐的这个角度出发。
你永远是需要实体的唱片的。
你的生活里永远可以融得下一个黑椒。
也不是说大家买不起这个黑椒对不对。
我觉得大家消费观变了嘛？
大家现在只会为自己特别喜欢的那个音乐。
就是甚至说就是我买这个实体回来不是为了听或者不是蠢为了听的。
更多的是作为一个战利品和纪念品的一个状态。
就比如你看我原来当初去七九八。
我刚接触黑椒我想买黑椒我跟他说有没有不那么MARS的。
然后他说这东西要什么黑椒版本吗？
那是个北京大爷
对可能是从新的口分出去的分到七九八九的大爷。
我们新的口的大爷都去对面那个珠宝城里面了。
总之那个七九八大爷那时候对流行歌手发黑椒版本这个事特别的不懈于不。
对他也不理解他就觉得那个东西不需要听黑椒。
因为你比如泡泊然后比如ROCK确实不需要听黑椒带来的那个ANNALOG的那个音色特征。
就可能更绝适合这个东西。
他需要那个特别温柔的那种动态的时候。
然后但是现在呢你会发现就甭管什么的也都要出黑椒版本。
只要这个歌手足够卖的洞都要出黑椒版。
然后真的好多人都会买而且那个黑椒做的超级漂亮。
是就比如说我这个时候又要举一下我们林冰的那个案例了。
他之前绝对不是一个大这个歌手就是流量多大的那种歌手。
但是他会有很多的各种椒彩椒羽毛椒。
然后什么新型的那个轻型的情人节限定椒就各种各样而且卖的很贵。
然后卖的很好我在日本找找到这些证刑对不好买。
然后你看像那个去年就是我就是夸张的是f1的那个原生蝶。
他韩子基莫做的嘛很好听然后他得有那么多电子鱼。
他还是要出黑椒版本那个黑椒里面还是灌水。
然后做成那个石油他是流体焦满。
然后里头就做成类似于石油的那个感觉的液体就非常怎么说呢？
就是他确实更适合作为一个百家或者就是你真的很喜欢这个东西。
你必须要为他花钱你就很大概率要买这种东西了。
对然后包括比如说我前段时间很像在塔店买那个DJ的黑椒。
就比如说像那个特别火的那个女DJ夏鲁特就是那个比利时的那个DJ。
他的黑椒你都随时可以在塔店里面买的。
我觉得就是每个人他都会有自己必买的那个那一张笛或者很多张笛。
然后钱你能在这买到我想要我得到。
对就是他不断的在给你这个东西。
而且流行音乐就无论是KpopJpop还是一些再次火爆的Citypop。
对然后包括像这种DJ的音乐电子Techno什么的。
就总有人会热爱其中的某某一类或者某一个人某一张专辑某一首歌。
然后你能让他买到这个是很爽的一件事情。
嗯对我就是那种我想要我得到然后被满足了的感觉是这个时代消费者的相反了。
对而且音乐或者说一张实体的唱片他能一直留在你的生活里。
对就比如说我现在真的很厌恶我们之前所走过的那个iTunes的那个时代。
是我觉得最恶心的一个时代就因为你处在一个混沌的年代嘛？
可能也没有去买很多CD你没有留存下来。
你当时可能下载的或者说你的歌单也没了。
嗯然后像我现在想要去重新唤醒我可能十几年前喜欢听的一些歌。
我就要给我那个老AppleNano去充电你知道吗？
嗯确实这个挺烦的你如果有跌的话直接塞进机器里放的好。
直接听就好了对然后像可能甚至更久之前。
比如说你小时候买的雨多天光可能他很老了那个跌。
但是他插到车里或者插到音响里他依然能听哦。
嗯对然后我就记得那天海鲁给我拿出了一张那个C-mo。
啊对
My lady 僕に魅仨してくれよ今日も君を夢に My honey 僕に何度も何度も言わしてくれ。
日本非常悠悠逆逆的一个说唱歌手。
然后其实他当时在那个就是零几年的时候。
他的那个曲风跟C-pop特别像的对说唱跟R&B结合起来。
是对然后就就我好好玩我之前从来没有听过这个歌。
然后觉得好好听嗯对。
但是你如果说你要想从你的流媒体找回一个电子的记忆那有点难。
嗯我也不可能说我在流媒体上挖了个坑然后竟然就能跳进去。
但是他翻我的老CD的时候他会很轻松的就被我的这些音乐中草刀。
还有一个我想到点就是听感的体验上。
就其实现在流媒体的那个听感体验不稳定。
就比如说我去听一张专辑就是很多音乐人其实他的专辑。
他的整体的想度然后歌曲间的音量平衡以及这一首和下一首之间的衔接。
他是认真处理过做过的对但是一旦上流媒体平台之后。
这个平台要不就会帮他去改变想度。
因为大家都手机里都有一个设置一个叫那个音量平衡。
就让这首歌听起来的那个想度和下一首差不多。
但实际上我经常听的几个歌手之间他们之间想度差异非常大。
他的那个倾向是不一样的。
然后他被平衡之后我觉得没有我手动去挑一个我喜欢的音量来的好。
然后同时现在苹果尤其Apple没有这个多分。
出了一个惹人闲的那个无缝过渡还是叫无缝协奸。
对DJ过渡的那个功能超级烂。
就是你这首歌没听完他给你加速加速完了直接混到下一首。
就是他把这两首歌然后可能是节奏或者是音调比较相近。
旋律比较相近的部分然后强行的做一个小变调人他俩能接上。
就是模仿了那个模拟那个DJ的过渡的那个感觉。
对但是就是很恶心。
对因为有的歌最后30秒可能就因此被跳过掉了。
是然后没有30秒吧？
可能就反正你的你喜欢那个歌手如果他真的是一个活很细。
然后循环不停的给你就是水哥水的转点。
我叫完整的听完之后歌手按过DJ了。
对对对然后你就要手动的去关掉他。
因为他现在这个DJ模式是一个自动的一个设置。
嗯对所以这个这个确实是流媒体时代。
就是流媒体时代没留下什么特别好的让你想要珍藏的东西。
对我现在就是越来越反感这些东西。
对所以就是比如说如果能够在家去播放一个专辑的话。
我们一定会用实体的解决方案。
对实体方案其实音质很好嘛？
好我们好像好久没有下楼了让我们来到这个塔店比较神秘。
大家不太平常会逛到的地下一层。
然后地下一层其实它不是一个常开放的一个空间。
它是一个演出空间。
你也可以理解为它是一个小型的Live House。
那比如说游客的话可以下去逛一下吗？
游客的话如果它开门让你逛应该是可以逛的。
对但是它更多的时候是有活动的时候才开。
因为它这个场地的活动我就看了一下。
还让我看得挺心动我挺想每天租一下的。
啊怎么说呢？
就是它会在官网上明确写出来。
它地下的这个空间可能容纳量能100人左右。
然后是一个小的Live House。
然后带现场有舞台灯光。
然后有舞台的音响系统。
然后还给你配了广播机去做那个直播或者路播用。
然后同时呢这些设备都是配人工的。
就比如它会配两个音响师傅。
然后一个灯光师傅和一个塔店的店员。
来伺候你6.5个小时。
帮你把这套系统跑通。
把演出做了也好或者做握手会讲座分享会。
然后小型活动你都可以让他们帮你去协助完成。
然后同时价格这么想一下也不是很高。
它6.5个小时包含器材搬进搬出时间的话是30万日元。
啊就一万多
对但是你就获得了一个就是在一个地标性的空间里。
专业的演出
对就相对专业吧？
起码小型演出它算是设备都挺齐全的一个状态。
那就很适合就是一个新人的音乐人。
或者说你是一个什么小的团体。
然后想要去做一个线下的活动演出。
小型演出什么的
他们是不是还可以卖票呢？
对啊这可以卖票的。
我看很多它的那个event活动的就是官方日历上。
就会写说哪天在B1有活动。
然后门票是3000还是5000。
然后或者是那种你需要消费一张底液。
然后进行参加这个前程会之类的。
那这个门票就是台电会抽成吗？
不知道可能他们他们不抽吧？
因为他毕竟都收了厂地费。
还会有电源协助你的。
那等于说如果你有一定的知名度。
然后去那搬这个活动。
你甚至可以通过收门票。
然后没准能转回来。
对啊？
而且就就其实挺多日本不那么火。
销量不那么高的艺人都在不停的做这种线下小活动。
来给自己拉销量
他可能到不同的店。
然后或者他选择不同的地区全日本的。
去跑跑这些小厂子。
来把自己的初始人气给积累起来。
嗯这样听下来是这个tower record。
真的是非常完善的一个。
对非常完善的一个空间的设置。
对
就是他他不只是那种。
就是说我要卖底液。
就是他他一直不是有强烈的那种只卖底的思路。
他一直都想把更多的东西往里塞。
而且是新的东西
对
我记得他们还会有一面墙。
他专门放那个新人。
啊对
这是什么国内新人吗？
应该是在三层J-POP的角落里。
然后他会把独立愿人。
就是你现在没签厂牌。
然后但是呢你有作品。
你可以把你的作品寄给tower record了。
寄售吗？
寄售
对然后他审核通过之后。
你就可以在那寄售。
然后他还会专门在那有电源。
那他
因为他选择了吗？
对所以他电源也会有推荐。
或者他有些底液是提供那个视听的。
你可以在那听一下。
是就是很好的一个曝光。
对
然后你作为一个在日本的独立音乐人。
如果想用这种方式开始获得曝光。
是挺轻松的一个事情。
没什么太高的成本。
对只要你自己把底液做出来。
就可以过去寄售
等于tower record的也因此。
应该是自己有唱牌。
就毕竟你看他发自己的那个歌单底液。
或者发这种新人底液。
他应该是都有这个对应的产品线。
或者有专人负责一下。
那到这里呢？
我们就把整个的tower record。
洗不压电给逛完了。
对
然后我们每层尽量给大家。
能放个一两分钟左右的声音在那里。
让大家感受一下氛围。
因为我觉得就是在现场的时候。
那个声音就是每层声音的不同。
以及他的那种很大音量。
灌进你耳底的感觉。
还是会很激发你
关于音乐的那个热爱和渴望的。
是的
然后我觉得做后总结一下吧？
我觉得关于这个tower record。
确实可以用他们那句slogan来概括。
就是no music no life。
无论是从上到下
还是你从下到上
你都能看到就是很多人。
无论你是一个音乐的爱好者。
还是一个发烧友
还是一个音乐人
还是一个电源对吧？
你都能够沉浸在这个音乐的世界当中。
你都能找到自己喜欢的东西。
而且就如果你第一次去逛tower records的系列店。
和你逛西伯亚店
你感受到的是我们今天带你的这种。
就是一个很像文化切片。
历史切片的感觉
然后但是如果你之后有去其他地区的tower records逛。
因为他在日本很多地方都有。
在东京有好几家
你会感觉到每家店又有自己不同的倾向。
然后他推的东西会更有特色。
更小众能带你找到刚好听的更小众的音乐。
对 我觉得吉祥寺就有一家。
虽然很小
但是就是会更精力一点。
可能也会更本地一点。
然后新宿的那家
他在一个大楼里
就是一个商场里
然后那个商场叫flex。
然后也非常推荐大家去逛。
因为那个商场里面几乎就没什么游客。
而且他里面有很多户外运动。
有一层基本上都是户外运动的那个牌子。
选品店吧算是
然后还有什么优衣库和gio。
是吧？
就反正很全面
还有那个mouse店。
那个new era就很好。
很好逛的一个商场。
就很安静
在新宿算是一个很安静的。
没有那么多游客的一个商场。
然后反正我觉得尤其是喜不压这家店。
就比如说你和你的朋友去逛。
你喜欢的可能是jazz。
然后他可能喜欢jpop或者kpop。
他真的可以让不同的人都能够找到自己喜欢的音乐。
然后你就慢慢的在那是听一点一点的。
按照姓名按专辑的名字去寻找自己想要的那首歌。
或者说你完全没带脑子。
没有想法
你就光靠电源推荐。
选择自己想买的这个专辑。
我觉得这种巨大的获得感是很难得的。
也是值得我们去拥有的一种体验。
我觉得是每个人都会喜欢的那种体验。
就是他比较有人味。
是
他不是说给你一个预设好的设计好的结果。
然后他还是更多的靠热情。
就是他整个是一个非常为爱发电的环境。
就是你喜欢你能得到。
其实你可能就能够和音乐一起。
然后度过这一生
嗯对
我觉得就是音乐这个东西。
他跟行业真的很不一样。
就是他的关键不在那张笔。
不在那个唱片
也不在这个人写了一首歌。
而是他要求的更多。
他要一个整体的环境。
是
就是你比如像cdpub这个东西。
七八十年代可能就写好了。
但是过了三四十年又红了又翻红了。
然后你一下去一个唱片店。
能找到所有cdpub的时候。
那个氛围感
然后以及你一下就和遥远的历史进行了一个连接。
对这个感觉是必须要一个这样的生态。
才能让每个人更爱音乐的。
对而且他需要持续下去。
他不能说某一天突然就死了。
对说我们终点时间不搞音乐了。
我们搞搞别的
没了所有唱片店全部推评。
或者人就不许搞
然后因为我觉得现在就是你说什么ai时代对吧？
但是你不能要求所有人他都能够成为一个搞it的人。
所有人都能成为一个工程师。
虽然说现在啊未来都是ai时代。
每个人都要学ai。
但是总有一些人他只会音乐吧？
我相信世界上有这些人。
然后他只能靠音乐为生。
但是如果他没有一个好的环境。
那音乐就是死掉吗？
对吗？
就是或者说这些人他因为热爱。
但最终走向了一个无奈的一个未来。
就是他只能当一个it。
或者去卖珠宝的是吧？
嗯对
就包括我也是啊？
我从小寻音乐
其实我父母可能也比较支持我。
然后我甚至可以有相关的工作。
但是我会觉得说可能这个环境没有那么的好。
或者我不想在一个乐团里面工作这样子。
嗯对
我前两天还在看就是现在。
尤其在国外
如果你念了像声音设计或者录音之类的这些。
其实在音频音乐行业里算很通用的东西。
那国内的就业其实非常窄。
是
就是你可能只能去要不大厂的少数岗位。
这些岗位还可能可能变成萝卜坑。
然后要不你就给去乐团。
要不就是去音乐公司忍受加班和薪水不固定这个事情。
哪怕你给大家一个去Tour Records卖碟。
当电源写推荐语的机会也好吗？
而且你小时候已经过去了。
就是说自己硬叠独立出道的那个时代。
因为我觉得像星库子他们那个时候好像是。
自己录完了歌之后还会自己推着三轮去卖死袋。
我觉得星库子就是属于他们活下来了。
就是他一直坚持或者说他熬过了一个时间段。
然后他等来了月下。
对对对
就是因为很需要积累嘛？
都是因为人先积累十几年。
然后有一个机会让他红。
对但可能在月下之前就死掉了很多很多。
对对对
然后包括比如我承昊我这一代的人。
我觉得没有这个乐团没有什么希望。
我就没有从事相关的工作了。
但是如果说那个唱片店一直都在。
我可能就是会有另外一种人生。
我觉得确实可能日本的唱片店改变了很多日本人的人生。
嗯或者说可能未来或者从现在开始。
就是这种体验他会变得更个人。
比如说你喜欢的爱好。
你需要让自己一直坚持下去。
嗯那你要想办法
就是所谓唱片店他就是有义务去让每个人都还是有机会能触摸到这个体验嘛？
嗯
因为现在越进入互联网的时代。
其实就是你能把体验这种很线下的事发送给一个人。
就是或者说触达到一个人。
让他能体验到这个过程是Tower Records之后活下去的那个动力嘛？
就像他现在正在做的一样。
他不断的多办活动。
你总能赶上一个你喜欢的去参加。
是
我记得他们也会常年和Fuji Rock这种音乐节合作对不对。
嗯对其实Tower Records他大多数在公众面前的亮相都是非常非常业的。
就是他特别不追求商业回报。
比如你说Fuji Rock就是他从Fuji Rock第一年就加入进去。
然后作为他们垃圾袋的赞助商。
他应该也赞助钱了。
但是他们主要的展示自己的那个平台。
就是环保袋
然后他会印一个塑料袋。
头三年的都还是就是他们直接拿Tower Records的买唱片的那个黄色袋子。
红色字的那个印着logo的袋去之后他开始卷这个东西。
他每一年Fuji Rock的那个设计都很独特。
对他会专门请设计师根据当年的主题。
或者当年他们认为需要去反映的一些公众议题。
然后去把它做成很精美的图案印在那个环保袋上。
我们也会放一些到short notes里。
就比如说02年他们请了那个横位忠则过去参与设计。
中间有一年我记得特别清楚的是那个季野清治郎。
20周年的时候他做了一个非常日式插画风格的海报就非常的好看。
这两年新的吧跟那个应该是描唱描唱的纪念款。
就是他Fuji Rock举办地的25周年纪念团也很好看。
是他这里选的这个鸟应该是那个新鲜线的那个线鸟。
然后像我们之前一直提的他那个Nomusic No Live的那个海报。
也算是一种广告但是他比较特别。
然后他一直就坚持的是同一句可号。
然后他认为的就是说Nomusic No Live就是Touradricle的作为一家唱片店。
想要传递给公众的他们的立场。
他希望展示就是我们店就是觉得Nomusic No Live。
然后我们需要把我们坚持的这个信念告诉大家。
让大家知道我是这样的一个人。
好的那么以上就是本期节目的主要内容。
然后如果大家喜欢的话欢迎大家在评论区后面互动。
然后也欢迎大家点赞转发收藏甚至赞赏。
嗯然后大家如果到时候去喜不压逛街的时候。
也可以去这个Tour Records逛一逛。
去找一找自己非常喜欢的CD或者黑胶啊？
好的让我们来到每期必备的彩蛋环节。
嗯然后今天彩蛋环节呢我们想做一个小型点歌台。
嗯嗯嗯就是我们自己点自己放。
就是因为我们其实中间讲了好多那个关于Tour Records的店的历史的部分嘛？
其实它这个店的历史跟日本近几年的那个流行音乐近几十年吧？
三四十年的流行音乐史是分不太开的。
因为你想就是流行音乐什么卖得好。
然后他就要学会在那个分野的音乐多去发掘一些碟都卖一些碟嘛？
所以我去做这期节目资料准备的时候就找到里边书讲Tour Records的故事。
然后里头他会附了一个大试年表。
他把每年的国际大试日本大试和日本当年的单曲销量排行。
唱片销量就是专辑销量排行的前几名都会附在同一个页面里。
然后我翻的时候我就发现就是其实很多名曲。
然后一些历史事件离我们并没有那么遥远。
然后你很难想象他们是在同一个时间点上发生的。
然后甚至你会在这些专辑的榜单里找到一些很奇妙的你熟悉的乐队。
然后所以让我们来进行一下点歌环节。
对回忆一下历史上的今天。
对就让这样来来来来随便说一个年份。
对然后我来讲这一年就是日本人。
发生了什么日本人觉得什么事比较大。
然后以及就是他们什么歌什么唱片卖得好。
对然后这样我觉得其实是一个挺直观的对挺有趣的历史回顾者。
好呀那我觉得首先我们就还是按照这个历史的长河的时间顺序来吧？
我觉得我肯定还是对90年代初非常好奇的。
因为90年代初就整个世界都发生着巨变嘛？
对我们也是90年代初的一代人。
所以还是挺想知道那个那个时代世界在发生什么？
然后日本的音乐在流行着什么？
对真的就是你把流行和历史放在一块看还挺有意思的。
那我们来看眼90年啊？
然后那年的世界大事呢？
他们认为首先是东德和希德的经济开始统一了。
那么柏林墙呢是在90年之前的一年半载左右。
就是崩坏的
然后在7月份的时候他们的这个经济运转终于东德和希德合并在一起了。
然后你在那个时候很多的莱卡身上就见不到那个。
是希德生产的那个资料了。
那之后就全是德国生产。
然后那个时候他们还说大事是那个伊拉克入侵的科威特。
那91年他们有没有记录说苏联解体这个事。
91年对血了
然后和苏联解体放在一块的大事。
他们认为是多国联军入侵伊拉克。
开始海湾战争
然后世界第一个3W网站开设。
就是那个万维网开始在这一年WOWW的那个开头开始了。
那那两年在流行什么音乐呢？
那两年我们来看单曲销量排行吧？
单曲销量排行大家可能比较熟悉的是90年第一名是BB Queens。
就是那个时候比较流行的一个J-POP的东西。
然后第二位大家可能熟悉一点。
第二位是Mimi Club。
Mimi Club它有两首代表作。
那个大家在看日本话话大会的时候。
都有大概率的机会听到他们。
是
91年排名第一的是小田和正。
哇
而且就是大家最熟悉的那个东京爱情故事的主题曲。
那东京爱情故事其实是91年的电视剧嘛？
对
然后91年排名第二的单曲是这个恰克与飞鸟。
可能就是像我一年老一点的这个日音关注者是知道的。
这个乐队太有名了。
经常出现在各个电视剧的段子里。
是
然后他们的歌在那个时候比较卖的好一点。
然后到了专辑排行榜基本也是刚才说的这几个歌就是排名比较靠前。
嗯嗯
那我印象中90年代就是反正整个世界的那个文艺还是都挺丰富的。
要不我们看一下96年左右吧？
96年世界动向首先是那个查尔斯黄太子和戴安娜王妃的离婚。
哦
对哦
天呐
这个12月是什么庇鲁大使馆吧？
应该是在庇鲁的日本大使馆被人占领了。
这整天都是这种事。
嗯
所以世界就从来没有消停过。
世界好像从来不太和平。
全是
然后在这一年非常火的曲子是第一名是Global的Departures。
然后排名第二名的这个大家肯定全都听过。
就是那个九宝天丽生的La La La Love Song。
也不一定全都听过。
我们上过我们节目。
对对对上过我们节目。
对我们我们打过这个歌。
La La La La Love Song。
对他那个去年日本的春晚红白。
然后那个九宝天丽生还去唱了这首歌。
嗯对
哦所以是30周年对不对。
对30周年这首歌去年。
然后专辑排行榜的话就是在日本国内是Global排第一。
然后后面几位里面大家比较熟悉的可能有安什奈美会。
哦安什奈美会
那个时候就已经开始了。
对啊而且卖专辑卖的好说明实力强嘛？
好那我们从这个上面找一找宇多田光的痕迹吧？
他是从哪年开始火的。
呃宇多田光
我看他第一次出现在这个榜单里是九九年。
哦千辛年之前
对而且他在这一年是两个榜都上了就是在单曲金曲。
金曲榜和这个芳月就是那个国内日本国内专辑的销量榜。
都是在前两位的
就全都是这个first love的。
对然后歌的话是automatic。
automatic作为单曲非常火。
所以automatic简直就是千辛年的代表啊？
对所以我觉得大家如果再看那个first love看韩主百合。
为什么这么喜欢宇多田光的这两首歌应该非常有感触。
就是他里面的那个时代精神就是对automatic的那个向往。
真的能代表九九年大家对新一年的那个畅相。
对
那九九年和两千年世界在发生什么呢？
九九年的时候我看一下。
美国上医院对克林顿发起了弹劾。
然后蓝牙1.0的标准发表了。
然后九九年的时候是澳门回归。
哦确实
哦对就是日本人其实在他这个年表里对中国的动向还是特别关注的。
那他们有没有记载九七年的香港回归呢？
当然有了
然后他还记载了在香港回归旁边就是丹娜的死亡。
九十年代末真的好精彩啊？
奠定了很多精彩的东西。
也很宣销
宇多田光automatic旁边排着的就是版本龙一的那个无拉bttp。
很多很多人其实好早之前就就已经活跃了。
对啊然后我们听到的时候可能都是十年后二十年后的。
是零几年呢？
因为零几年我记得我在新街口的时候还是可以随便买碟的。
那个时候华语音乐也非常的蜂蜜。
那么我们来看一下零三年零三年他这个确实世界依然挺乱走到的。
就是首先第一件事是。
飞碟
这是第二件事
第一件事是那个好像是美国的那个挑战者号太空飞船直接在空中发射解体了。
然后然后就是中国的那个飞碟。
这个叫什么新型飞研SARS。
SARS
然后在日本的话是日本大事里面有。
公器圳的千语千语获得了奥斯卡最佳动画成品。
然后那一年的单曲来自于smart。
就是中级正共啊？
然后那个牧村拖栽他们的那个团。
世界名曲
世界名曲应该翻译叫世界唯一的花吧？
嗯对
然后这个歌我相信所有就是。
可能上过A站B站的都听过。
因为那个歌实在是太火了。
然后后面排名的还有这个福山雅致中岛美雪。
他们都在这一年的top 5里面。
然后这一年最不可思议的是。
你根本想象不到就是阳月的这个专辑销量码。
是谁
有一个大家非常熟悉的名字。
sapop听众非常熟悉的名字获得了第一位。
sapop吗？
对就这一年有一张sapop专辑。
周杰伦
no
然后这一年就有一张sapop专辑。
这一年有一张sapop专辑。
周杰伦
no
平静节
你绝对猜不到
平静节小答案
是女子12月房的beautiful energy。
这张专辑获得了当年日本阳月销量第一。
然后女子12月房连续两年进入了榜单的签计名。
还都是专辑榜
女子12月房真的很厉害。
我记得那个年代就是电视上所有的。
尤其是央视吧？
CTV3
CTV2
整天都是女子12月房。
而且她们都很美
头发很洒
黑肠脂
对吧？
然后身材也都很棒。
然后就是很洒的
拉二壶
然后女子12月房。
确实当时还被三德丽请去拍乌龙茶广告了。
就也是非常帅的
然后站在山头的那个感觉。
现在就是浪节
她们上浪节了是吗？
没有啊？
然后之后我不知道她们就消失了。
像新加坡的蝶店一样。
消失了
我觉得可能她们太成功了。
你想她当时卖蝶卖到日本都能卖那么活。
肯定还是可以有隐退的资格了。
不用再出来挣扬老钱。
12月房就12人。
当然了
不是AKB48其实有少百人吗？
所以日本人一直喜欢这种多位女生。
组成的团体的形式的。
所以女子12月房也是她们的菜。
而且又都是美女
而且就每个人都身怀绝技。
像武林高手一样
而且她不是那种精致性美女。
天然感的美女
那我们再来看一下08年吧？
08年也是一个重要之年。
对
然后这一年对于日本人来说的大事是。
首先雷曼兄弟破产。
这确实是个世界大事。
搞笑的是在日本大事纪里。
他们记了一条是
3月和伊士丹合并成为3月伊士丹。
神经病
这一年iPhone还在日本国内首次发售了。
然后之前一直都是水货状态。
终于就是合约机自买了。
你有没有觉得有一种在玩大富翁的感觉。
确实突然间走到格子上发生了一个什么事。
对
你的钱就会受到
就没了
然后这一年的单曲榜里面。
大家比较熟悉的出现了阿拉希。
那个阿拉希都是带来了。
对
然后另外有一首名曲可能是那个Green。
大家不一定熟悉这个团。
但是一定听过那个Kiss Aki他们那个。
然后这一年的邦岳。
就是日本国内音乐的专辑排行榜里。
依然出现了这个宇多天光和安逝奈美会。
你想安逝奈美会从刚才。
1996年
1996年到现在12年了。
还有他
然后以及还有可顾可乐。
可顾可乐也是一个。
可能有点老像
恰可与飞鸟那个级别的东西吧？
对
大家不知很了解
很正常
然后这一年他们都很喜欢。
大家不知很了解
很正常
然后这一年他们听养月。
开始会听麦当娜了。
就没有鱼子事儿的法。
然后还有Code Play。
他们就是没有好好总结一下C-POP。
如果你这个是个C-POP的大使年表。
我觉得对他满分
好让我们来看一个一几年的吧？
你来挑一个
我觉得12年吧？
12年
世界大势里有什么？
世界人口突破70亿。
然后北朝鲜的金正恩当书籍。
然后南朝鲜的飘景会当总统。
确实又是一个就是。
就很熟悉的名字
但是你说时间其实也过去了十多年了。
然后这一年东京还数起了天空树。
天空树已经也十几年了。
对
然后这一年确实好看。
这一年的单曲排行前五名全是一个。
全是一个团
AKB
嗯
12年完全被那个。
AKB也占据了
对就是卖握手圈这个事儿。
真的很能卖蝶
其实那个时候我作为一个喜欢日本文化的观众。
就是你没得选
就是那个时候如果你想听一点音乐类的。
半股民音乐类的翻组的话。
你没办法新一点的只有AKB。
然后他们上综艺刷的也多。
然后那个时候因为也流行。
所以国内什么字幕组搬运。
他们的综艺也特别多。
然后雨多天光也还没回归是吗？
对
他09年还是10年宣布退隐之后。
你们就没得听了
对没得听那个时候日音真的清黄不及。
然后就全靠AKB称唱。
嗯
那年好在杨月有什么？
阿达尔的21和那个。
魔龙5之类的
啊？
Lincoln Park。
天呐
就是怎么说呢？
就日音不行
那什么时候日音就有了。
米金全师这种新一代的接棒人呢？
让我们来看看什么时候。
就是说这个专辑销量榜里。
或者单曲销量榜里出现了。
米金全师这些年轻一点的名字。
我跟你说我现在看到2018年。
单曲榜前5名是耐木版AKB。
耐木版AKB
然后你是不是也贡献了很多销量啊？
哎呀对我这边不算是走销量的吧？
哎就真的到当时有那个饭头去团购。
然后因为普通的代购吧？
他买的渠道可能是那个二手货什么的。
他就不进入唱片链销量。
但是那个时候大家为了达榜什么的。
大家要找那个正规的代购。
然后他会说我一定从唱片店买。
然后有那个唱片店小票的。
然后别人一张小票告诉你那是正版帖。
现在都变成要加入会员是不是。
对你要去买那个翻clab的会籍。
对我朋友就是snowman的会员。
那个时候AKB其实也搞会籍。
一直都有
但是AKB时代可能运营的就好一点了。
就是你加入会籍
你会有什么专属的手机壁纸啊？
然后成员定期给你发短信啊？
生日的祝福
对对对有类似于这种运营。
我就更贴近个人一点。
真的2018年这一年。
终于就是在这个邦月的专辑销量榜上。
就是出现了一些新的名字。
就是出现了那些不是小天和正。
不是宇多天光
不是韩式代表会的名字。
那么这一年这个是迷迹宣师吧？
然后他的boot lag在这一年在这个邦月专辑里面上网了。
然后当然他前面还拍着安适耐美会。
然后他后面还拍着一堆天光。
就真的日音就靠这么几个老人撑到现在了感觉。
直到2020年
就是2020年我觉得也算是一个比较大的节点吧？
嗯又一个十年
对
就18年之后我觉得19年后没什么存在一个20年。
我比较喜欢20年纵结。
对一景了嘛？
对
这一年就是全是新冠大事。
这一年的单曲排行出现了新的这个榜单的继承人。
Snowman和Sixthones。
他在这个新冠大事里面。
这个Snowman和Sixthones。
他们两个的那个联合单曲。
然后占据了第一位。
然后Snowman现在是日本。
就是演唱会动员人数。
动员数最高的那个团体。
是我也想去
就是日本人终于推出了新人。
不再让AKB他们大棒了。
然后这一年也是那个。
剧场版《鬼迷之刃》的那个无限列车片上映。
然后是历史上最快达到110元的动画电影。
然后阿拉西这一年宣布无限期的活动休止。
然后他们今年就又活了。
然后阿拉西在这一年就靠引退这个事情。
又冲进了那个单曲销售吧？
就是他们不行了就先引退。
对然后也冲进了专辑销售吧？
然后再过几年再付出。
好套路
我们哪天散了没有。
我们没有什么粉丝。
除了刚才说那个Six Stones和Snowman的联名款。
占据第一 第二名是耐姆版。
第三名是阿拉西 第四名是AKB。
第五名还是Snowman。
就这年的单曲还是被这种类优相产。
也罢清罢失 被团体霸占着。
但是这一年在日英的专辑排行榜上。
米军选师再次获得第一名。
然后胡子南第二名。
然后王牛第三名
就是至此为止你感觉之音终于有了小弟们。
可以接一接前面那些阿姨的玩意。
这几年就确实有更多的人出来了。
对包括云亚索比好像他前期都没做过专辑的选范。
他可能主要都是网络或者动画的主题曲就配出去了。
这一年阳月的专辑第一名你绝对猜不到。
谁呢？
是冰写全二的原生笔。
连LEDGo他们都能专辑卖报。
对日区的专辑销量榜里。
原生笔是单独算一张的。
它一定会被计销量。
对
他们recorder里是不是有一个区域专门是卖原生笔的。
外国的就在七层
然后日本的可能就在四层。
对对对
总之原生笔确实还卖挺好的。
好那么以上就是本期的所有内容。
然后让我们下次再见。
再见
you get the golden touch。